[Music]
Amazon Web Services popularly known as
AWS or AWS cloud it's essentially a
secure cloud service platform that
offers compute power database storage
content delivery and a whole lot of
other functionality to help businesses
scale and grow they actually brought
about a paradigm shift in the world of
infrastructure as a service so now you
can have infrastructure and you can pay
as you go you can use only what you want
and then you don't have to worry about
the reliability or uniformity of the
service so somebody who is having one
server versus somebody who is having a
thousand servers in the cloud would get
the same sort of reliability same sort
of service across all of the regions
they also get the computing power the
storage the networking the database as
much as any other irrespective of size
and scale and region now let's look at
something called AWS global
infrastructure now this is what AWS is
made of so we have regions which are
nothing but geographical locations and
as of now there are sixteen regions and
you can see that they are spread all
over the world now each region consists
of two or more availability zones now
what our availability zones essentially
they are fault tolerance data centers
which consists of one or more facilities
this is where AWS would put their
servers and storage hardware devices and
each region as I said would have two or
more availability zones to help with
their disaster recovery and fault
tolerance and availability they also
have something called edge locations
which are used for content delivery so
the other part of the content delivery
network where you can deliver your
content with the lowest possible
redundancy throughout the big cities and
all over the world so the first question
that comes to mind is is AWS for me and
am I going to use servers in cloud am I
going to use storage and cloud so let's
look at the use cases for AWS and I like
to call it AWS for everybody so we'll
look at the size of the enterprise and
then we'll look at the rules that we
have
around all of this organization
irrespective of if it's an enterprise a
startup or a small or medium business so
let's say you are a big enterprise and
then you know your priority would be
security availability of service
cost-cutting resource optimization
faster deployment AWS gives you tools to
achieve all of this if you're a startup
the first thing you would want is you
want to scale up without paying upfront
you want that elasticity to go from
probably a few hundred users to a
million users in a matter of minutes
maybe hours and you don't want to pay
upfront for that thing you can't very
well do that you also want an automatic
service where you can simply focus on
building your product and not the heavy
lifting or shifting of managing
something like databases or managing
easy instance answers you really don't
want to do that you want to spend all of
your time in writing the code in making
that product beautiful and getting it
out the door as easily as possible as
often as possible and AWS gives you the
tools for doing just that if you are
small or medium business you would
probably not have a very large team that
would take care of all those things that
could be storage that could be security
that could be servers that could be
databases an AWS gives you a host of
managing services to take care of all of
those things and you have a budget you
don't want to spend more money than that
you want to know what is going in what
is going out of your network
AWS gives you tools to audit to track to
budget your monthly costs all of that
let's say you're an IT manager if you're
an IT manager and your priorities are to
get the work out the door as early as
possible to make sure that all
activities that are happening in your
account are recorded somewhere that all
the costs that is being allocated to
your department is consumed in the
manner that it should be then AWS is for
you if you're a Solutions Architect and
you are developing a solution for a huge
enterprise scalability security audit
ability traceability and cost are the
drivers then AWS is a platform of choice
for you if you are a system
administrator and you want to provision
resources your hardware resources your
storage resources your computing
resources on the fly then AWS makes your
life really really easy whereas if you
are a software developer and all you
want is your code to be checked and then
released on the click of a button you
can very well do that if you want to do
something like distributed tracing to
know what is going on in your micro
services AWS has services that will help
you with that if you're a tester and you
are testing loads and loads of apps and
you of course want to test on iOS
Android and all the versions over there
then you might not simply have all of
these hardware devices with you and AWS
provides a service where you can simply
go and test your application on any
number of devices with any number of
operating systems and again it's all in
there pay-as-you-go model if you're a
web developer or a database
administrator you would want to have a
lot of services where you do not have to
do the heavy lift and shift where you
don't have to work on managing the OS or
you know managing the security patches
and AWS gives you tools to do all of
that
they have hosts and hosts of managing
services which are offered in software
as a service model and then all you do
is run your code on it and put your data
in it and you don't have to worry about
it as an executive if you are a CEO or a
CIS oh you're concerned about the
security part of it you're concerned
about the scalability and the
reliability part of it an AWS gives you
host of services which will integrate
seamlessly into your enterprise's data
center so it's not as if it's all cloud
or no cloud at all and there are various
services in terms of storage in terms of
connectivity where you can simply plug
in your data set
with AWS and then the data transfer
would happen seamlessly and of course
securely at the CFO you would want to
keep your cost under check you do not
want to be surprised at the end of the
month or at the end of the quarter an
AWS will give you billing by the hour
and a billing dashboard with cost
Explorer with budgets and whole staff
reports that will make your costs very
transparent which department is using a
lot of costs or which department is over
budget or what resources are generating
most costs from my account and you can
segregate all of the costs across all of
the divisions across all of the
resources and you can provision them you
can reserve them and if you know they
are going to run in production you can
buy them for a period of one to three
years and then you can get a lofty
discount of up to 75% on their own
demand price if you're a project manager
and you have lots of these resources
like a web developer or tester or
systems administrator or services
architect working for you then AWS there
can't be a better place than AWS because
AWS gives you so many features such as
cross account access such as
organization such as structured advisors
such as Resource Manager so that you
know exactly what is happening in your
AWS account or all of your AWS accounts
and if you're a network engineer you can
create your own logical network in AWS
you will have your own CIDR block and
you can have as many IP addresses as you
want to create your network and this
will be your secure network and you can
connect it to multiple networks in the
cloud or you can connect it to your
network on-premises and it makes your
life really really easy
there is however one question that comes
to mind when we talk about AWS does AWS
have its own technology doesn't have its
own product how well do they really
integrate with open-source technology or
open-source products or I have licensed
software what do I do with them when I'm
going to use AWS
essentially AWS seamlessly integrates
with all the major open source
technologies and all the major licensed
software such as Microsoft or Oracle or
s AP and for open source technology you
have Apache Hadoop cluster and you can
have them in clouds seamlessly in memory
engine they have Redis ElastiCache
elasticsearch you can use Visual Studio
Eclipse chef puppet SharePoint all these
ecologies integrate really really well
with AWS and in some of the cases
something miniscule is there but you
don't have to worry about running the OS
or operating the security patches for
the software because AWS will do it for
you it just makes your tasks really
really easy on cloud because you don't
have to worry about managing but you
simply worry about how you can make the
best use of this resource the same thing
goes with languages so there are
developers who must be thinking does AWS
have ap is how do I talk to AWS services
how do i integrate with AWS services
do I have to exclusively use AWS ap is
or can I write something of my own and
what are the languages that all of these
services support there are a host of
services to support pretty much all
major languages you have PHP Java dotnet
Python nodejs Ruby c-sharp JavaScript
AWS provides support and SDKs for
Android development iOS development and
all of these languages as well so rest
assured that irrespective of the
language that you are working for and
the software that you are using it will
seamlessly integrate with AWS
Hey once you become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here